[Music]
whatever happens next
the people of prader luz won't emerge
easily
from the shadow that fell on the sunny
resort 13 years ago
well people will just say thank god for
that um it will
hopefully remove the stigma to some
degree
um because undoubtedly in the early
years
a lot of people ceased to come here on
holiday americans in particular abhorred
the idea of coming
to part of the loose of all places in
the world because she
could have their children snatched from
under them there are few in the village
who remember the new suspect
from the years he lived here but even
then
christian b a 43 year old german drifter
was a predatory sex offender two years
before madeleine vanished
he carried out a violent sex attack
nearby
in this villa he raped an elderly
american woman he was masked and armed
with a knife
he tied gagged and beat his victim he
filmed the attack
police are now exploring possible links
with other attacks along the algarve
coast
hazel bean was a holiday rep in 2004
when a masked man with a machete broke
into her apartment
beat and raped her and filmed it
it was prior to russia 20 miles from
prior deluge
her attacker had a german accent when
hazel bien read the details of christian
b's rape conviction she said
her mind was blown there was such
striking similarities
to her own ordeal she's given a
statement to scotland yard and said
detectives told her
they were taking her case seriously and
contacting the authorities here
this book reveals many more sex attacks
in the years before
and after madeleine's disappearance
again a masked intruder
break-ins at holiday apartments and
children as
victims these are possible
similarities between the suspect
christian bee
and other people who have committed
crimes
so one would really want to be looking
closely at them to see if these are just
coincidence or if impa perhaps we're
seeing a pattern here
detectives say they've received a
thousand bits of information
since they launched appeals about their
new suspect
martin brunt sky news portugal